[Musik]
die Diskussion um den textgenerator Chat
GPT wirft erneut die Frage auf was von
dem was Menschen können können Maschinen
besser
wenn Chat GPT in der Lage ist
eigenständig hochwertige Texte zu
verfassen was werden Programme der
künstlichen Intelligenz in Zukunft noch
können welche Fähigkeiten die bisher den
menschlichen Alltag bestimmten werden
wir verlieren und was gewinnen wir über
die Chancen und Risiken künstlicher
Intelligenz spreche ich mit der
Kulturwissenschaftlerin Mercedes Bunds
vom Kings College in Mannheim
[Musik]
von uns ist künstliche Intelligenz
intelligent
ja sie ist intelligent allerdings anders
intelligent als wir uns das
normalerweise denken also künstliche
Intelligenz bedeutet ja es ist so wie
menschliche Intelligenz weil der das
Wort künstlich ist ja dann auf den
Menschen bezogen und sie ist keine
menschliche Intelligenz müsste man
eigentlich ein anderes Wort dafür
erfinden absolut ja ich meine man könnte
es einfach Maschinen Intelligenz nennen
aber das haben wir leider verpasst und
jetzt haben wir recht viel an der Backe
was wir eigentlich nicht wollen an
Diskussionen Worten ja und da müssen wir
heute in der Sendung durch
versuchen wir mal rauszukriegen was
diese Maschinen Intelligenz
unterscheidet von menschlicher
Intelligenz piagei hat gesagt
Intelligenz ist das was man einsetzt
wenn man nicht weiß was man tun soll das
ist so die schönste Definition von
Intelligenz die ich kenne wie sieht das
beim bei maschineller Intelligenz aus
weiß die was sie tun soll weiß sie nicht
was sie tun soll und wie kreativ ist sie
also sie weiß natürlich nicht was sie
tun soll und das ist auch der große
Unterschied würde ich sagen zur
menschlichen Intelligenz weil man sagt
ihr ja was sie tun soll und wenn man sie
dann sozusagen trainiert dann lernt sie
von ganz vielen Daten etwas zu verstehen
was was jetzt ganz toll ist weil im
Grunde genommen das faszinierende warum
wir uns hier auf Treffen ist dass die
Maschinen oder Computer zum ersten Mal
Bedeutung analysieren können rechnerisch
und das gab es sozusagen vor überhaupt
nicht da haben jahrzehntelang
Computerwissenschaftler daran gearbeitet
und Sprache und Bilder zu verstehen ist
wirklich ein ganz neuer Schritt ja sie
sagen verstehen ja also der Sprung
besteht darin künstliche Intelligenz
kann zumindestens mit Bedeutungen
umgehen das soll ja etwas was man sehr
lange gar nicht wusste ob man da diese
Stufe überhaupt erreichen würde ne aber
verstehen bedeutet ja eigentlich so nach
unserer Vorstellung von verstehen
über ein Bewusstsein verfügen
das ja also es ist eine andere Art von
verstehen es ist ein maschinenverstehen
Bewusstsein würde ich sagen hat die
Maschine nicht ein ganz wichtiger Punkt
von Bewusstsein den auch meinen Kollege
in England anilset der
neuro-wissenschaftsprofessor ist
sozusagen in seinen Texten immer wieder
rausstellt ist es gibt einen freien
Willen was will ich machen wo will ich
mich hinrichten Maschinen haben ja
diesen freien will nicht die werden ja
immer programmiert also selbst da einem
generellen Modell wird ja gesagt mache
das und das und dann sorgen wir uns
darüber was das Modell macht aber die
Sache mit dem Bewusstsein die hat die
Maschine nicht das ist für uns etwas
schwierig zu verstehen weil wir sie ja
wissen die Maschine spricht mit uns als
ob Sie ein Mensch wäre also Chat GPT
diese dialog-systeme die kommen für uns
rüber als ob das Menschen sind die auf
der anderen Seite mit uns sprechen und
erst wenn man sozusagen die Technik
dahinter versteht dann kapiert man nee
also da wird sozusagen die menschliche
Sprache imitiert menschliche Sprache
kann man stochastisch ganz toll
berechnen die ist strukturiert die hat
bestimmte grammatische Regeln das kann
man alles mathematisch sozusagen
errechnen und für uns ist es dann halt
wie als ob wir mit einem Menschen
sprechen sie haben das bestimmt auch
schon mal ausprobiert und sich darüber
amüsiert
es ist ja so sie sagen ja gerade sie hat
keinen freien Willen in der wenn man
sich die Evolution anguckt dann sind
irgendwann Lebewesen mit einem
elementaren will entstanden spätestens
mit der zwei Geschlechtlichkeit nämlich
dem Willen sich zu baden irgendwann
natürlich kommt auch der Wille dazu sich
zu ernähren der ist kein bewusster Wille
das ist so ein dumpfer trieb oder
Instinkt oder sowas ne das heißt also
die willensstruktur die ist Hunderte von
Millionen Jahren alt und dann kommt ja
erst zu einem viel viel späteren
Zeitpunkt in der Evolution
sowas wie Bewusstsein bei einigen
wenigen Tieren dazu und Intelligenz ist
ein um sich in einer komplizierten
Umwelt zurechtzufinden deswegen sind die
intelligentesten Tiere normalerweise
soziale Tiere weil die komplizierteste
Umwelt die es für ein Lebewesen
überhaupt gibt sind andere Lebewesen
also wahrscheinlich der der gleichen Art
aber nie so genau weiß was die tun und
so das heißt also in der Evolution
führte der Weg bei Menschen über den
Willen und über seine Physiologie und
seine Körperlichkeit zu Bewusstsein und
Intelligenz dann gibt es Menschen die
fürchten sich davor dass Maschinen
irgendwann auch Bewusstsein und Wille
entwickeln können meine Frage ist halten
sie das verdenkbar dass ein nicht
physiologisches Wesen das also nicht
diesen evolutionsweg gegangen ist immer
das Beste für seinen selbst Erhalt zu
tun tatsächlich über solche animalischen
Dinge wie Bewusstsein oder gar Wille
irgendwann verfügen könnte wäre das
denkbar das ist jetzt ganz schön dass
Sie das animalisch genannt haben das
Bewusstsein das ist eine sehr große
schwierige Frage Einstellung die sie da
aufgemacht haben weil wir wissen ja
beide dass es Intelligenz und
Bewusstsein auch nicht so klar definiert
sind in der Wissenschaft und das ist so
ein bisschen schwierig ist weil manche
sagen ja auch Mose haben Bewusstsein und
haben eine bestimmte Intelligenz ihr
Umfeld sozusagen zu gestalten und sich
in bestimmte Sachen sehr langsam zu
bewegen oder Pflanzen Bäume und so
weiter das ist also recht schwierig da
so eine
Hierarchie würde ich mal sagen
aufzumachen zu sagen okay der Mensch hat
das meiste Bewusstsein die anderen die
haben weniger und durch die ganze
Evolution sind wir so langsam dahin
gekommen
ja dann diskutiert man so und ich glaube
die Angst die wir vor den Maschinen
haben ist die Angst dass wir uns selber
eigentlich in den Spiegeln und wir haben
dann Angst dass die sich so verhalten
wie wir nämlich Weltbeherrschung ganz
klar alle sind quasi so sehr schnell im
Alter eines fünfjährigen Kindes das so
ich will aber und wir denken jetzt die
Maschinen die müssten doch genauso sein
wie wir so ich will aber das kennen wir
sowieso ja genau ja und dann nie wieder
rauskommen ja und ähm und das weiß ich
so interessant finde in meiner Forschung
ist dass zu gucken wie kann man das ganz
anders beschreiben wie funktioniert das
anders das bedeutet nicht dass man jetzt
sagt es gibt da keine also natürlich
passiert da was wenn diese Intelligenz
mit uns zusammen arbeitet und
kollaboriert das ist überhaupt gar keine
Frage dass ich die Welt verändert aber
die Sache jetzt einfach so zu sagen ja
aber wir müssen nicht wirklich studieren
was da passiert weil wir kennen das ja
alles Menschen das wird genauso die
wollen die Welt beherrschen da halte ich
halt das denke ich dass da der große
Fehler passiert im Moment in der
Diskussion ich bin da vollständig bei
ihnen ich glaube auch dass wir uns vor
den falschen Dingen fürchten also wenn
wir jetzt Angst haben der böse Wille der
in der Maschine ist und der auch noch so
typisch menschlich ist dass man andere
unterdrücken und unter Jochen will und
so dass das quasi aus einer Absicht oder
aus dem Willen heraus dass das sicher
nicht passiert ich denke mal wenn man in
einem einsamen Haus im Wald ist dann ist
es sehr viel besser sich vereinbrechern
zu fürchten als vorgestern und ich denke
immer dass wir in der Diskussion über
die Möglichkeiten und die Gefahren von
k.i ständig dabei sind uns vergeistern
zu fürchten würden sie das genauso sehen
ja also die Spekulation ist unglaublich
und das Problem dabei ist natürlich das
ist so ein bisschen als hätte man kann
was können wir wissen was sollen wir tun
was können wir hoffen man hätten nimmt
nur den letzten zum Teil was können wir
hoffen und verwendet den dann was können
wir fürchten und da rennt man dann
sozusagen bis ans Ende des Ganges ganz
aufgeregt oh Gott wir müssen uns
fürchten die Maschinen übernehmen unsere
Rasse unsere Spezies es wird alles ganz
furchtbar und was sich die Frage
absurderweise ist diese große Furcht von
der wir ja oft in den Zeitungen auch
lesen und wo es dann offene Briefe gibt
und so weiter und so fort diese große
Furcht ist absurderweise etwas wo sich
die Leute ja auch drin verstecken weil
die Tatsache wie künstliche Intelligenz
Alltagsleben der Menschen ankommt die
ist wie man im englischen sagt Messi das
ist alles ein bisschen verwuselt dass es
nicht so klar dass es schwierig und es
ist viel eleganter diese große Angst zu
haben als zu sagen oh Gott ja gucken wir
mal hin wie arbeiten die Maschinen was
können wir eigentlich wissen was sollen
wir denn jetzt genau tun diese Fragen
stellt man sich überhaupt nicht
weil man halt so sich so bequem mit
dieser sauberen Angst aufhalten kann sie
sehen sehr ähnlich ich frage mich
manchmal ob es eine bewusste oder nur
eine unbewusste Ablenkung ist also so
den Fokus der Aufmerksamkeit auf die
Geister richten statt auf die Einbrecher
uns also weniger mit der Frage
beschäftigen die KI was kann die jetzt
schon und was wird die in unserem Leben
verändern auf der einen Seite klar zum
Guten aber auf der anderen Seite eben
auch zum Schlechten und realistische
Gefahren aufzuzeigen statt sich mit
Fragen zu beschäftigen was für 50 oder
100 Jahren sein kann oder sich in
Science-Fiction Fantasien zu ergehen die
eben glauben wie sie das ja gerade schön
beschrieben haben die natürliche
Evolution der Maschinen müsste auf die
genau gleiche Art und Weise verlaufen
wie die der Menschen und zu den gleichen
Charaktereigenschaften führen ich würde
von Ihnen gerne wissen was sind für Sie
die wichtigsten Einbrecher also was was
sagen sie das was macht ihn das
mulmixste Gefühl an der gegenwärtigen
ki-entwicklung was meinen sie sollte man
zurecht fürchten naja uns Menschen
natürlich
also wie gehen wir mit der KI um
haben wir da die richtige
Herangehensweise wissen wir überhaupt
welche Verantwortung wir genau brauchen
und damit umzugehen also wenn die KI
negative Auswirkungen hat dann liegt das
natürlich nicht daran dass die Maschinen
den Fehler machen sondern dass wir
sozusagen den Rahmen nicht genau gesetzt
haben und nicht gut gesetzt haben und
das halte ich für das größte Problem
sie haben ja dann schönes Beispiel auch
einen Text drüber geschrieben wie das
ist mit der Moral und den Maschinen
können wir die Maschinen die Maschinen
Moral einprogrammieren und es wird ja
jetzt zum Teil auch versucht und dieser
dieser Wille der Menschen doch gerne
Sachen abzugeben und sich nicht mehr
verantwortlich zu fühlen das halte ich
bei künstliche Intelligenz für das
größte Problem Gott sei Dank haben wir
uns schon in der Diskussion ja etwas von
automatisieren zum hin bewegt das ist ja
schon mal ganz schön aber wie sieht das
mit dem Moral Beispiel auch beschrieben
haben selbst wenn man da jetzt mit
constitutional ai and tropical also eine
Firma versucht da ja zu Werte
einzuprogrammieren und so Prinzipien
indem man diesen Basismodellen noch ein
anderes Modell vorsetzt das funktioniert
natürlich bis zu einem bestimmten Teil
gut aber das kann natürlich dann im
Endeffekt keine Moral und trauen kann
man dem Ding dann trotzdem nicht sie
verstehen viel mehr von Informatik als
ich also wie man Maschinen Moral
technisch einprogrammiert davon habe ich
nicht die geringste Ahnung das können
sie viel besser nachvollziehen als ich
das tue aber sie halten auch die
Reichweite eines solchen Ansatzes für
begrenzt also wir können uns nicht
darauf verlassen dass wir sagen okay wir
haben jetzt einen Fehler gemacht wir
haben sehr sehr schnell KI entwickelt
mit zum Teil beachtlichen Fähigkeiten
bildgeneratoren sprachgeneratoren und
jetzt ist die ganz wichtige Aufgabe dass
wir die quasi moralisch Programm ändern
da glauben Sie nicht so richtig dran
dass das geht nee ich glaube das
spannende also jeder der ich kann nur
allen Menschen raten wirklich so ein
bisschen zu studieren wie künstliche
Intelligenz funktioniert man muss dazu
nicht programmieren lernen man muss
keine neuronalen Netze aufstellen und es
geht so ein bisschen um den Mechanismus
im Hintergrund und wenn man dann mal
dann näher reinguckt dann merkt man dass
die funktioniert super gut also in ganz
vielen Bereichen Bild Erkennung Sprache
man kann den auch sozusagen moralische
Prinzipien einprogrammieren durch
Sprache geht das natürlich sehr viel
weil die moralia über die Sprache stark
funktioniert
aber alle KI funktioniert immer gut und
dann plötzlich macht so Plopp geht gar
nicht macht großen Fehler und als Mensch
steht man so da denkt sich warum machst
du denn diesen albernen dummen Fehler
und das Problem ist dass wir mit dieser
Art von Maschinen Intelligenz die ist
uns nicht vertraut wenn wir jetzt ich
sag mal ein Auto Motor haben der fängt
dann so ein bisschen an zu dann wissen
wir schon oh Gott lange fährt das Auto
nicht mehr und dann hört er irgendwann
auf die maschinenintelligenz
funktioniert super gut und dann wie
gesagt UPS plötzlich geht gar nichts
mehr und wir haben das Problem dass wir
bei der maschinenintelligenz sozusagen
Performance und Kompetenz
auseinandernehmen müssen die Maschine
hatten ganz tolle Performanz das
bedeutet aber nicht sie hat Kompetenz
und deswegen geht das dann plötzlich so
macht sie so ein Fehler aus der
technischen Logik denkt die Maschine ich
mache alles richtig das ist ja auch das
große Problem
und sie macht aber von der menschlichen
Perspektive aus diesen Fehler
ja also die Maschine in der Performance
viel perfekter als der Mensch aber da
sie offensichtlich nicht über bewusst
sein im menschlichen Sinne verfügt ist
sie nicht in der Lage ihr eigenes Wissen
zu wissen und kann sich deswegen nicht
grundsätzlich korrigieren sondern nur
innerhalb eines begrenzten Rahmens und
deswegen stellen uns die Fehler so
dramatisch auf die sie macht die hat
also es sind zwei Sachen zum einen hat
sie tatsächlich nicht eine zweite Ebene
um zu reflektieren das stimmt nicht ganz
es gibt ja auch wie ein forcement
Learning also da gibt es schon was was
in die Richtung geht das Problem ist
dass die Maschine es ist eigentlich
ihren technisches Problem und die
Maschine lernt ja aus ganz vielen
kleinteiligen Daten und die Art wie sie
Sprache aber auch Bilder angeht passiert
dass sie sich aus ganz kleinen Pixeln
die nebeneinander stehen das große
zusammensetzt das heißt denn man kann
das schön an der Bilderkennung erklären
eine Maschine erkennt Textur aber keine
Form das bedeutet wenn ich eine
Katzenform habe und ich packte eine
Elefanten haut rein dann ist die
Maschine zu 80 % sicher Elefant ist aber
eine Katzenform weil jeder Mensch würde
sagen Formen Trump Form ist wichtiger
als äh als äh Textur also ist eine Katze
und diesen dieser feinen teiligkeit der
datenerkennung die für die Maschine dazu
du ganz so zu mit ganz großer Sicherheit
zu sagen Elefant und das haben wir auch
in der Sprache also bei Chat GPC gibt es
ja so das große Problem des
halluzinierens und das kommt alles aus
dieser technischen anderen Art die Welt
zu sehen das heißt also mit anderen
Worten die die KI sieht eine Million
Bäume aber kein Wald ja genau ja also
gut ist ein sehr viel schärfer im
Einzelnen bei völliger Gleichgültigkeit
im ganzen steht sozusagen dieser
holistische Element der ist ja
Ungenauigkeit voraussetzt die Teil nicht
zu interessieren macht einen Wald aus in
der Wahrnehmung Gewalt ne ansonsten sehe
ich so und so viel Kubikmeter
Holz also das ist der maschinenblick auf
die Dinge ja so ist es absolut die
Maschine die kann quasi den Wald vor
lauter Bäumen nicht sehen wie man das im
Deutschen so schön sagt und verwirrt
sich dann eben also die Daten also das
kleinteilige ist immer wichtiger als das
großteilige und deswegen sagt man ja
auch also sagen auch die
Computerwissenschaft die
maschinenintelligenz hat keinen Begriff
von Welt oder kein großmodellbegriff sie
lebt auch nicht in einer Welt nein also
Menschen finden sich hervor in einer
Welt lebend und das ist ja etwas was die
KI von sich aus nicht hat sie findet
sich in einer Regel basierten Umgebung
vor aber nicht das was wir Welt nennen
ich will diesen Gedanken vielleicht mal
versuchen noch klarer zu fassen am
Beispiel des Themas was im Augenblick
alle beschäftigt
ne dass man das was wir jetzt gerade
gesagt haben über diese diese
Detailliertheit auf der einen Seite bei
der Gleichgültigkeit für das ganze auf
der anderen Seite und dieses nicht in
einer Welt leben sondern in einer
vorgefertigten Welt leben das wäre das
mal versuchen so ein bisschen klarer zu
machen am Beispiel von Jetski ja also
wie das funktioniert wissen inzwischen
viele Leute es gab sehr viele
erklärendungen dazu eben klar gemacht
haben dass aus einer unglaublichen Summe
von Daten und Informationen die Maschine
eben in der Lage ist Fragen zu
beantworten das ist jetzt erstmal ein
toller Schritt weil vorher musste man
suchen mit Hilfe von Computersystemen
und jetzt kann man direkt in ein Dialog
eintreten ist das auch für Sie was viele
Leute sagen die dritte technische
Revolution nach dem Buchdruck auf das
erstes und im Internet als zweites oder
finden Sie das übertrieben ja und nein
also
tadschipity kann ich alle nur warnen
bitte auf keinen Fall als Suche benutzen
ist nicht die nächste Google also nicht
das nächste Google das geht so auf
keinen Fall es ist aber eine große
Revolution weil wir haben das noch nie
geschafft da das wir also das Schreiben
automatisieren konnten das ist das erste
mal und es war auch recht
putzig zum Teil des zu verfolgen wie das
entstanden ist weil die Maschine am
Anfang sich keine Paragraphen merken
konnte das hat das ist ja eine
also Wortvorhersage also die Maschine
sagt ja immer wenn hier dieses Wort
david ist dann ist dann das nächste Wort
recht ganz klar und das Problem ist so
ein bisschen dass die Maschine sich nur
einen Satz merken konnte und nicht
wusste was das übergreifende Thema sind
dann immer so abgelenkt war und einen
furchtbaren Text produziert hat der sehr
putzig zu lesen war aber halt
Kauderwelsch und erst kürzlich hat man
das technisch so hinbekommen dass die
Maschine jetzt sozusagen zusammenhängt
über mehrere tausend Wörter mir eine
gute Antwort
geben kann aber es ist technisch oder
faktisch nicht richtig die Maschine hat
keine Ahnung was eine Differenz zwischen
Fiktion und Fakt ist und wie sie sagen
sie hat keinen Weltmodell es ist aber
trotzdem eine Revolution würde ich sagen
weil schreiben ist denn der Welt der
Menschen ja was ganz besonderes wir sind
die einzige Spezies die schreibt und
lies der Tiere haben ein Instrumente die
benutzen Instrumente Tiere haben Sprache
aber schreiben und lesen das tun nur wir
Menschen Spezies und das finden wir
natürlich jetzt auch etwas verwunderlich
dass jetzt da so ein Ding daher kommt
und das auch macht deswegen kümmere ich
mich jetzt auch nicht so viel darüber
dass die Leute dann sofort denken oh das
ist jetzt Dialogpartner und so weiter
und so und da gibt es dann natürlich
auch die Gefahren dass Leute sich in die
verlieben oder
da so eine enge Beziehung eingehen und
da müssen wir erstmal also wir haben im
Moment keine Ahnung wie wir dieses
generative schreiben in die Welt in
unsere Welt einbauen werden und das ist
für mich natürlich erstmal unglaublich
spannend das ist ein Irrer Moment da
sozusagen dabei zu sein also jetzt kann
man sagen es gibt ja Vorteile die liegen
auf der Hand ja wie viele Menschen
verbringen ihr Arbeitsleben damit
langweilige Texte verfassen zu müssen
für die man keine Kreativität braucht
also ich rede mal von von unsere
Bürokratie ja ist voller halbkünstlicher
Intelligenz ja sie ist sozusagen der
Sinnbegriff von halbkünstlicher
Intelligenz ist es wird nicht von
Maschinen gemacht aber es ist
regelbarisiert
ja es geht mir kommt auf meine
persönliche Meinung meine Individualität
meine Kreativität überhaupt nicht drauf
an ja bei zu Arbeits- und Texten die ich
als sociate in einen Anwaltskanzlei
mache oder ob ich irgendeiner Verwaltung
arbeite das ist diese ganze Welt der
halbkünstlichen Intelligenz die wir
jetzt durch voll künstliche Intelligenz
ersetzen können da ist mir klar worin
der große Vorteil besteht wenn wir bei
uns auf der anderen Seite dran gewöhnen
dass die Maschine schon relativ bald
bessere Texte schreiben kann als der
Durchschnittsdeutsche
stellt sich doch die Frage warum der
Durchschnittsdeutsche eigentlich noch
schreiben können muss oder warum das
überhaupt noch lernen soll in der Schule
wie wird man unseren Kindern in 20
Jahren begreiflich machen bei enorm
fortgeschrittenen
sprachgeneratoren warum man denn
überhaupt noch schreiben lernen muss
naja
lesen muss man ja schon noch lernen das
wird ja nicht automatisiert also das ist
natürlich auch automatisiert aber wir
wollen ja als Menschen auch gerne noch
selber lesen aber ich glaube man muss
das gar nicht so hoch hängen dass das so
also da gibt es immer dieses Argument ja
wir verlieren eine Fähigkeit dadurch das
was automatisiert wird dass sich da was
verschiebt da haben sie natürlich
absolut recht da wird sich was
verschieben
wie gut der Durchschnitts deutsche jetzt
wirklich schreiben kann das können wir
uns mal fragen das lassen wir vielleicht
mal kurz offen ich glaube aber dass man
sich nicht so viel Sorgen machen muss
weil wir haben das ja auch erlebt dass
wir jetzt in der Schule schon mit einem
Taschenrechner rechnen
und so viel anders wird das natürlich
auch nicht mal rechnen nö aber die Sache
dürften entsetzlich schlecht sein
gegenüber früheren Zeiten das Positive
Argument wird zu sagen wir brauchen es
eben auch nicht mehr wahrscheinlich den
Leuten die so
ja vielleicht im Servicebereich arbeiten
und bedienen obwohl die haben auch iPads
mit denen sie mittlerweile an den Tisch
gehen brauche ich rechnen und dann
bezahlen und das sind relativ
überschaubare Rechenoperationen im
Vergleich dazu was ich in der Schule
alles lerne aber wie gesagt also ich
glaube auch nicht dass wir so das Gefühl
haben oh Gott wir haben an die Fähigkeit
das Rechnens verloren und uns geht
wirklich was ab also ich mache mir da
nicht so viel Sorgen und ich denke auch
wir haben in unserem menschlichen
Geschichte schon sehr viele Fähigkeiten
verloren im Handwerk zum Beispiel und
das sind auch intelligente Fähigkeiten
und dann gibt es natürlich immer
besondere Experten Ecken wo das
weitergepflegt wird das ist ja auch sehr
gut dass man das so macht aber das ist
der große Unterschied zum Schreiben sie
haben ja gerade gesagt ne schreiben das
was uns vom Tier unterscheidet rechnet
übrigens nicht das ist sehr spannend in
welcher wahnsinnigen Geschwindigkeit
Schimpansen Zahlen ordnen können und so
sehr beeindruckend aber das Schreiben
ist nun wirklich das was uns von allen
anderen Tieren massiv unterscheidet die
Lesefähigkeit die Schreibfähigkeit diese
unglaubte Reichhaltigkeit des
sprachlichen Ausdrucks wenn das jetzt
verkümmert als Fähigkeit ist das eine
ganz andere Hausnummer als die
Rechenfähigkeit also die Frage ist wie
funktioniere ich als als Staatsbürger
wie funktioniere ich in der Gesellschaft
tatsächlich wenn ich irgendwann in einer
Kultur lebe in der ich eigentlich nicht
mehr richtig lesen und nicht mehr
richtig schreiben kann hier steht doch
viel mehr auf dem Spiel als beim Rechnen
ja
nein also ich glaube
es steht sehr viel mehr auf dem Spiel in
dem Sinne dass ich sozusagen der gesamte
Textbereich verschiebt und definitiv
auch ja dass er sehr entscheidend wird
wie sich dieses Feld verändert da haben
sie absolut Recht aber dass wir jetzt
denken der Effekt des automatisch dass
der Mensch per se verkümmert weil er
sozusagen das nicht mehr praktiziert ist
denke ich nicht wenn man im Moment sieht
was diese Maschinen können was churchy
BD kann und was nicht kann haben sie ja
sehr schön gesagt kann sehr einfache
Texte sozusagen Texte die keine
besonderen Intelligenz brauchen in denen
ich mich nicht besonders ausdrücken will
sehr gut diese Texte die zu schreiben
lernen weiß ich nicht wie wichtig das
ist aber was man braucht und wo es
sozusagen auch sehr viele Berufe geben
wird jeder der einen inneren
Erbsenzähler in sich hat hat eine sehr
große Zukunft eben weil diese Maschinen
die Fakten nicht richtig
verstehen die können in Unterschied
zwischen Fakt und Fiktion nicht
verstehen wenn ich jetzt bei Chat GPG
eingebe welche Texte hat David Brecht
jetzt nehmen wir mal ganz anderes Thema
zu dem sie noch nichts geschrieben haben
zur
Kunstgeschichte im 19 Jahrhundert
geschrieben sage ich jetzt mal ich hoffe
dazu haben sie kein Buch geschrieben
dann wird er mir das jetzt mehrere Titel
aufgeben die sie dazu geschrieben haben
einfach weil die Frage ist ein bestimmte
Zahlen Muster für die Maschine und da
muss dann auch das entsprechende zahlen
muss dazu raus die Maschine weiß nicht
unterschiedlich die weiß der muss jetzt
eine Buchtitel her er muss eine Buch
Zusammenfassung her dass sie sieht im
mathematischen so und so aus und da ist
keiner hat zur Hand hat er findet sie
das jetzt einfach dann kann ich der
Maschine sagen das stimmt aber nicht
kannst du noch mal nachgucken dann sagt
die Maschine auch ohne völlige Probleme
wie gesagt keine Moral ach stimmt da
sich einen Fehler gemacht deswegen also
man kann man kann man weiß nichts über
Fakten und all diese Texte die
produziert werden durch diese neue durch
dieses generative schreiben in Zukunft
brauchen Menschen die da Erbsenzähler
mäßig drauf gucken und sagen Fakt
checken nein ja stimmt schön nein auf
keinen Fall jetzt könnte ich ja
provokant sagen es ist auch für Menschen
unglaublich schwer Fakten und Funktionen
zu unterscheiden naja aber für eine
Maschine ist es noch schwerer als für
den Menschen ja da sind wir definitiv im
Vorteil ja also das läuft ja vielleicht
darauf hinaus dass man sagen kann die
Maschine hat einen quantitativen
Wahrheitsbegriff ja das heißt also wenn
ich jetzt als Mensch das ist jetzt so
die philosophische Frage die mich
beschäftigt ne wenn ich als Mensch
versuche zu ergründen was Realität ist
dann lehrt mich die Philosophie
Geschichte das ist wie Realität nicht
gibt und dass ich auch keine brauche
also für mein tägliches Leben brauche
ich nicht die objektive Realität sondern
ich nehme die Eindrücke wahr und die
Informationen finde ich
vertrauenserweckend weil die von dem und
dem stimmt und vieles sind Routinen und
Automatismen so so nicht reflektiertes
wissen wo ich davon ausgehe das ist doch
so ohne dass ich das überprüfen kann ich
schreibe mir also meine Welt irgendwie
zusammen ohne dass ich dafür eine
objektive Realität als Vorlage brauche
das ist in bei Maschinen ja anders da
gibt es ja eine Vorlage nämlich die
ganzen Datensätze die da eingespeist
sind die werden quasi zu einer Art
objektiver Realität auf ihrem Basis die
Maschine arbeitet wenn ich jetzt die
Vorlage also das im Internet
vorgefundene Wissen manipuliere nicht
jetzt eine Millionen Informationen über
sie einstelle die alle nicht stimmen und
alle in dieselbe Richtung deuten und
über Bots ja lasse ich das viral gehen
bis zum geht nicht mehr dann wird
natürlich Chat GPT hingehen und wird das
vorfinden und wenn das in riesiger Zeit
vorhanden ist wird das natürlich durch
das Bild über Sie mitbestimmen
dein normaler Nutzer stellt sich jetzt
noch die Frage kann ich Chat GPT
Vertrauen ja und gehört dem hinterfragen
nein auf keinen Fall aber mit mit dem
zunehmendem Gebrauch wird das eine
solche Normalität werden möglicherweise
dass keiner mehr das hinterfragt
Variante A ist wir übernehmen das alle
weil wir gar nicht uns die Mühe machen
können das zu überprüfen
Variante B ist ich glaube überhaupt
nichts mehr ich vertraue keinen Bildern
mehr die mit bildgeneratoren hergestellt
sind ich weiß nicht ist das ein
bildgenerator stimmt das wirklich hat
Putin das gesagt hat man ihm das in den
Mund gelegt ich weiß das alles nicht
mehr und das würde dann zu einer Kultur
des Misstrauens führen also entweder
werden wir stumpf für die Unterscheidung
von Fiktion und Realität oder wir werden
vollständig skeptisch vollständig
skeptisch würde ich mal empfehlen aber
vollständig skeptisch hat einen Haken
moderne Gesellschaft leben davon dass
wir Dinge vertrauen die wir nicht
durchschauen also Schale Gesellschaft
also in Diktaturen brauchen wir das
nicht da werden die Leute durch Angst
zusammengehalten also die Gesellschaft
dann mache ich dann glaube ich schon was
habe ich kein Ärger Kriege in
freiheitlichen liberalen Demokratien
muss ich Vertrauen ja ich muss
Informationsquellen Vertrauen ja ich
muss Aussagen Vertrauen ist ja auch
Politikern bis zu einem gewissen Grad
jedenfalls Vertrauen vertrauen ist eine
ganz wichtige Währung unserer
Gesellschaft und wenn ich in Zeitalter
der unendlichen Manipulierbarkeit lebe
und eigentlich nichts mehr Glaube und
überhaupt grundsätzlich nicht mehr
vertraue dann wage ich die Prognose
fliegt unsere Gesellschaft auseinander
ich bin mir nicht so sicher
man man weiß ja also wir kommen ja aus
einer Zeit wo das schon mal so war also
in der Zeit wo es sozusagen keine
fotorealistische Abbildung gab hatten
wir ja auch schon mal eine Situation die
bei den also ich sag jetzt mal
Mittelalter weil das ja bei den Bildern
auch schon genauso wir hatten damals
keine Fakten Fotografie gab es nicht und
es ist ja nur eine bestimmte Phase in
der Geschichte der Menschheit wo wir
diese faktisch abbildenden
ja Medien hatten und es gibt einen davor
und es gibt eventuell wie es jetzt
aussieht auch einen danach wir kennen
das im Umgang ja schon zum Teil aus dem
Photoshop also wir wissen wenn wir ein
Bild sehen hier selfie mit HI wissen wir
sollte ich mal nicht trauen dass das
wirklich dass virale Bild dass ich in
den sozialen mediene dass ich den trauen
kann das war jetzt auch das Bild mit dem
Papst wo er diese weiße Papa Jacket an
hatte das auch durch die Medien gespuckt
hat das war natürlich mit generiert und
für so etwas müssen wir oder haben wir
natürlich auch einen instinktiven Blick
absurder Weise dass wir dann so ein
bisschen Wissen okay den Bildern können
wir trauen den Bildern können wir nicht
trauen aber das Problem dass sie
ansprechen ist schon ganz richtig weil
das größte Problem dass ich sehe ist das
im Moment und da bin ich auch nicht
alleine mein Kollege Hannes Bajor der
ist da auch der Meinung die Tatsache
dass es nur kommerzielle Anbieter sind
die textgenerierung und Bildgenerierung
sozusagen
anbieten und dass die Technologie so
einen großen Bereich unserer Welt unsere
Lebenswelt mittlerweile einnimmt das ist
so wie sie so eine Macht geworden wie
die Politik eigentlich war nur für die
Politik haben wir Institution wir haben
Wahl wir haben Kontrollmechanismen für
die Technik fällt uns das schwerer als
wir sind natürlich gerade dabei so
europäischer künstliche
intelligenzgesetz wird jetzt gerade
verabschiedet in den nächsten Mon merken
aber es ist doch sehr langsam und die
Tatsache dass wir auch als Menschen da
nicht mehr einfordern wir müssen
künstliche Intelligenz nicht nur
kommerziell einsetzen wir müssen auch
fragen wie können wir Gesellschaft damit
verändern und besser machen und die
nicht nur auf der Arbeit einsetzen
sondern können wir die für Klimawandel
einsetzen was können wir eigentlich also
haben wir eigentlich eine Vision
künstliche Intelligenz nicht nur fürs
Business einzusetzen sondern auch für
andere Werte und das fehlt natürlich
auch weil wir lange digitale Technologie
nur so als ökonomisches Werkzeug
angerufen sage ich jetzt mal
philosophisch haben und dann nicht
eingefordert haben dass da auch eine
gesellschaftliche Vision dahinter steht
die wollten wir uns dann so liefern
lassen aus der Wirtschaft wie kann das
sein dass die Europäische Union diesen
gesamten Bereich KI in der
Militärtechnik gar nicht regulieren will
und haben sie da auch keine Angst davor
dass wir also Killer drohnensysteme die
wir da haben und so dass die weitgehend
auch mal außer Kontrolle geraten könnten
und dass sie zu einer der größten
Gefahren der Menschheit sogar werden
können da passiert mit der Technologie
etwas ganz anderes und wir wissen noch
nicht genau wie das einzudämmen ist und
was wir da machen können es ist nicht
eine Technologie die man so ganz einfach
verbieten kann weil dazu ist sie zu
alltäglich man kann nicht einfach sagen
wie beim sozusagen oranium wir nehmen
das um das mittlerweile raus dann kann
auch keiner mehr Atomwaffe bauen toll
das geht halt nur mal bei Drohnen nicht
der Champagner ist aus der Flasche
rausgesprudelt ja und den kriegen wir
nie wieder dahin zurück und die
Kontrollmöglichkeiten sind eigentlich
hinten die in Entwicklungen immer viel
zu stark hinterher oder vielleicht sind
auch unsere juristischen
Kontrollmöglichkeiten die wir bisher
haben
stark genug
ich denke immer als die
gentechnikdiskussion war Ende der 80er
90er Jahre da hat man sich darauf
geeinigt dass wenn ich jetzt mal
tatsächlich an embryonenforschen will
vielen Ländern war das überhaupt erstmal
verboten aber die wenigen Israel und so
die vorgeprescht sind dass man sich
gesagt hat okay aber nur unterschränkten
Auflagen das heißt also die Genehmigung
dauert schon ewig und dann genau geguckt
was wird da gemacht damit er nicht
irgendwie ein Mensch herangezüchtet wird
und so jetzt wäre ja die Fantasie zu
sagen das müsste bei der Entwicklung von
künstliche Intelligenz genau dasselbe
sein also wir lassen nicht sagen jeder
bastelt mal drauf los dann lassen wir
das in die Öffentlichkeit dann haben wir
gleich 600 Milliarden Nutzer und dann
gucken wir mal ob das gefährlich ist
oder nicht gefährlich ist sondern dass
man das von Anfang an antizipiert und
direkt in die Entwicklungswege bereits
juristisch eingreift ohne nicht im
Nachhinein etwas zu regulieren was man
vielleicht gar nicht mehr regulieren
kann würden Sie dafür plädieren
ich glaube leider ist die gegen die
Realität ist etwas vor Wochen da als
dass wir sagen okay wir nehmen A oder B
mm
das Problem ist regulieren danach
also das Problem sagen wir erst mal mit
davor regulieren ist wer entscheidet
denn in welchem Wertesystem wir davor
regulieren das ist natürlich dann auch
die Frage
wer hat das wissen wer macht die
Entscheidung deswegen denke ich
Gleichzeitigkeit also man kann nur
regulieren von dem man weiß dass ich was
entwickeln kann und wir haben ja lange
in der KI gehofft dass wir selbst
fahrende Autos haben hat uns die KI aber
nicht gebracht finde ich manchmal schade
weil ich auch selber eigentlich nicht
Auto fahre und vielleicht ist es auch
gut wir haben ja öffentliche
Verkehrsmittel das ist ja auch ein
selbstfahrendes Auto und auch das
klimafreundlichere würde ich mal sagen
aber
es ist eigentlich so ein bisschen das
Problem dass wir mit der Regulierung oft
zu langsam sind und ähm wir überlegen
uns erst was da passiert und
gleichzeitig ist die KI natürlich auch
sehr schnell also bei dem europäischen
künstlichen
intelligenzgesetz sieht man das ganz gut
die waren so voll in Fahrt plötzlich kam
dann Jet GPT und dann war so oh jetzt
müssen wir aber noch mal nachbessern
der Grund war dass es sich um die
sogenannte Foundation Models das heißt
also allzwecktechnologie und die waren
nicht vorhergesehen also man kann diese
Technologien zum Segen der Menschheit
einsetzen und die größtmöglichen
gefahren damit machen und in was für
Paragraphen soll ich solche Techniken
denn überhaupt einfügen oder wie soll
ich wie könnte ich wenn sie sowas neu
entwickelt wurde jetzt mit meinem
Gentechnik Beispiel nach welchen
Kriterien soll ich denn entscheiden wenn
ich etwas so universell einsetzbares
habe ob ich da jetzt irgendwas verbiete
oder reguliere oder nicht aber man hat
da schon Techniken und das ist auch
wiederum meine Frage ist warum steckt
man nicht mehr Förderung in so eine
Technik zum Beispiel es gibt in der
Computerwissenschaft immer wieder
Forschung ob man zum Beispiel so eine
Art Muster in Text Generierung rein
Gries und Wasserzeichen quasi wo dann
die großen Firmen die das anbieten sagen
okay ja wir lassen ein Wasserzeichen in
die textsignatur mit einfließen damit
können wir dann ganz klar unterscheiden
was sind Computer erzeugte Texte was
sind Menschen erzeugte Texte
versuche die zeigen das könnte gehen und
wie das halt so immer ist wenn man ein
Feld entwickeln will damit dann das gute
bei rauskommt muss man da auch Geld und
Investitionen reinstecken und Menschen
wissen und das natürlich wenn man die
künstliche Intelligenz jetzt immer nur
auf Wirtschaft pocht und sagt ja wie
können da möglichst schnell Geld
rauskommen dann wird das Wasserzeichen
nicht entwickelt und deswegen denke ich
da fehlt uns oftmals die Balance also es
gibt verschiedene Mechanismen zu sagen
wir können das unterscheiden wir können
da Sachen regulieren und sind können da
auch schneller sein und sagen wir zum
Beispiel können wir wie Italien einfach
gesagt Chat GPT geht bei uns nicht weil
privat dass die privatinformation
unserer Bürger ist nicht geschützt und
Sie müssen da jetzt mal nacharbeiten
bevor wir das wieder öffnen für unsere
Bürger könnten wir auch sagen ja sorry
Chat GPT geht nur wenn sie in
Wasserzeichen einbauen und dann würde
natürlich open als Firma der Chat GPT
gehört erstmal händeringend was daran
tun dass die 350 Millionen europäischen
Bürger jetzt vielleicht dann doch
erreicht werden indem sie ein
Wasserzeichen konkrete politische Agenda
das Wasserzeichen zu zu fordern und
damit zu drohen die Systeme nicht
zuzulassen das könnte so in die Richtung
gehen ja ich habe noch eine Frage zum
Schluss
ich frage mich wie gut ist künstliche
Intelligenz wir können das ja auch
versuchen am Beispiel Chat zu machen in
der Lage das neue zu denken
ich frage das deswegen weil die ganzen
Datensätze die jetzt hier genutzt werden
sind ja bisher vorhandenes Wissen und
alles was der Text mir dann man gibt es
sozusagen schon vorgefunden ja und dann
neu sortiert arrangiert stimmig gemacht
aber so ein richtiges Möglichkeit sind
so in alternativen zu denken oder ganz
anders zu denken oder so ist ja
eigentlich da nicht vorgesehen sondern
je mehr solche Texte eingesetzt werden
manchen Bereichen ist das völlig egal
aber in anderen Bereichen vielleicht
nicht wiederhole ich bereits bekanntes
Wissen
erzeuge aber eigentlich in dem Sinne
kein neues ich neige vielleicht auch
dazu wenn ich dann viel Umgang damit
habe die bisherigen Wissensstände als
Normen zu betrachten das ist sozusagen
das was da ist und das woran ich mich
orientiere also werden die
Gesellschaften noch kreativ sein wenn
ihre Hilfsmittel es eigentlich auf der
inhaltlichen Ebene nicht sind also sie
müssen es auf der technischen Ebene sein
aber auf der inhaltlichen Ebene sind sie
ja eigentlich überhaupt nicht wie gehen
wir damit um mit mit Möglichkeit Denken
von Musil stammt diese Unterscheidung
ist Wirklichkeit Sinn gibt muss es auch
Möglichkeiten finden die Frage nach dem
Möglichkeiten sind der KI finde ich sehr
sehr spannend also könnte es nicht sein
dass uns eine unglaublich moderne
Technologie gleichzeitig
gesellschaftlich aufhält das wäre die
konzentrierte Frage weil sie auf
bekanntem Wissen beruht und weil sie
bisher nicht gut darin ist das neue oder
das andere zu denken also ich würde mal
sagen wir sind hoffentlich so klug die
Maschine nur dann einzusetzen wenn wir
nichts Neues von ihr wollen also wir
haben ja vorhin auch gesagt die Maschine
funktioniert am besten wenn sie quasi
Texte für die man jetzt nicht besonders
viel Kreativität braucht marketingtexte
alltagstexte administrative Texte wenn
sie solche Texte generiert
dann ist es wahrscheinlich am
effektivsten das sind jetzt auch nicht
so Texte wo ich das neue erwarten möchte
gleichzeitig wenn wir uns das mal
überlegen gab es ja sozusagen mit der
mit dem mit der digitalen Technologie
gab es auch eine rückbesinn auf das
Materielle also man sieht das auch in
der Buchproduktion ganz schön da wird
dann
die Farben von den Bücher Covern also
von den sogenannten
couch-büchern die man dann sich so zu
Hause schön hinlegt die Materialien die
auch Künstler einsetzen in der
Produktion alles ist plötzlich viel
wichtiger geworden weil wir so viel im
digitalen Raum sind also es gibt dann
immer wieder diese Gegenbewegung ich
glaube nicht dass ich dann denke nur
weil wir also wir werden
Textproduktion nicht in der
Gesamtgesellschaft überall einsetzen
dazu halluzinieren die Dinger zu viel
das geht nicht in den Gebieten wo wir
sie einsetzen brauchen wir das neue
hoffentlich nicht ich denke aber dass
eine ganz andere Art und Weise dessen
was ist neu dass wir das noch mal das
ist wichtiger wird zum Beispiel aber man
darf auch nicht
ja
unterschätzen dass so eine Maschine
andere Sachen findet also man hat das ja
so schönes gibt ja diese berühmte
dieses berühmte Beispiel das die Mainz
alphago also so eine Maschine die ein
bestimmtes asiatisches Spiel spielt
schachbrettspiel oder nicht Schachbrett
aber Brettspiel dass sie einen
bestimmten Zug gemacht hat wo alle sich
gedacht haben wow was ist das denn das
hat sie natürlich nicht gemacht weil sie
das neue gefunden hat sondern weil sie
eben diese andere kleinteilige
Herangehensweise hat von der ich vorher
geredet habe und weil sie über diese
kleinteilige Herangehensweise andere
Züge macht also wer ich glaube nicht
dass wir uns mit der künstlichen
Intelligenz langweilen werden sie wird
uns schon überraschen aber sie wird uns
nichts Neues bringen also das war ja
schon schönes Schlusswort aber ich habe
am Ende noch eine Frage wenn sie sich so
die Welt in 10 Jahren vorstellen
wir reden jetzt nur über die technische
Entwicklung über die wir hier gesprochen
haben ist das was wo sie sagen ich bin
total gespannt weil wir haben so viele
faszinierende Möglichkeiten was wir
jetzt technisch alles machen können und
wir können vielleicht viele Probleme
lösen die wir bisher nicht lösen können
oder sagen Sie sich oh weh ja wohin
läuft das Ganze welches ist das stärkere
Gefühl bei ihm also ich bin eigentlich
in der Mitte weil gut wäre wenn man die
menschliche Geschichte studiert dann
merkt man ja immer ganz genau dass die
Menschen im Endeffekt bleiben wir ja die
gleichen und wir setzen das ein und wir
sind nun mal nicht immer die
intelligenteste Spezies auch wenn wir
recht viel Intelligenz haben deswegen
bin ich da nicht so hoffnungsfreude
strahlend dass wir die künstliche
Intelligenz zum Besten unserer
Gesellschaft einsetzen aber ich bin
schon neugierig darauf wie das sich so
entwickeln wird
das Gespräch
[Musik]